Hello.
How are you?
I'm here, directly from São Paulo,
to communicate a great new feature
from the world of Google Cloud Platform.
My name is Ricardo,
and I help companies in Brazil
to migrate to Google Cloud.
Our team works on cases
such as SulAmérica,
which uses solutions such as App Engine,
CloudSQL and Datastore
to create innovative applications
and a highly scalable
hybrid environment and performance.
Another interesting case
is that of Contabilizei,
a start-up
that provides accounting services
for small and medium companies
across the country
and runs all of its highly scalable
infrastructure within the GCP,
using services such as
the Google Container Engine and BigQuery.
The new region of São Paulo will enable
clients to process and store
their data in Brazil.
This means consistent gains
in speed
for all of our clients in the region.
Our performance tests demonstrate
a 50% to 95% reduction in latency
when we serve clients
throughout South America,
compared to any region
of the United States.
Google Cloud is continuously
making investments
in infrastructure and services
for your business,
whether they are in Argentina, Colombia,
Chile, Peru or Brazil.
With all of this,
we are more than eager to see
what our clients
will create and build
with the arrival of our region.
Thank you very much.